[Musik]
das podcast ist brought you the munich
zuerst wollte ich was betonen bzw
bekannt machen ich habe schon in der
ersten sitzung gesagt
dass eine weitere quelle von
informationen und ideen über hat die gp
wie ist mein podcast des clubs
also die und die parks folgenden sind
kostenlos downloaden oder einfach über
internet unmittelbar zu hören
allerdings wenn man ein paar euros
ausgeben will
ich habe vergessen zu erwähnen es gibt
auch die buchfassung das ist das buch
und dieses diese band decks gehe
eigentlich genau das ab was ich in
diesen wolle in dieser vorlesungsreihe
gespräche also vorsichtig viel
detaillierter als ich hier bestellt habe
und platon und aristoteles auch die
unmittelbare nachfolger von partnerre es
dort bis der zweite bank ist in
erscheinen also das kommt seinen den
nächsten monaten war heraus und das dext
die restliche antike philosophie ab der
realistische größe vieles wieder
spätantike ist natürlich auf englisch
aber wenn diese audio fassung nichts für
sie das richtige ist vielleicht das buch
also das gebe ich einfach einmal rum
es wäre gut wenn ich das buch zurück
bekommen würde
gleich nach der vorlesung okay heute
werden wir einen dialog namens weiteren
gesprächen
das ist wie oft bei plattform einfach
der name einer eines von den
protagonisten übrigens die titeln sind
damit von platon selbst sind vielmehr
später in der antike ausgedacht also die
haben keine bedeutung
die auslegung des dialogs könnte man
sagen
und dieser dialog ist sehr berühmt unter
anderem weil da weil man da die zähne
erfährt wie sotheby's stirbt spoiler
alert sorge die stirbt am ende also ich
war tut mir leid dass ich die spannung
jetzt für derbe aber die also dass das
ist deutlich die zähne wo man ihn im
gefängnis sieht wo er ein letztes
gespräch mit seinen freunden genießt und
dann senkt er
herr mark weiß jemand wie herr macht auf
deutsch heißt wie bitte das klingt auch
gefährlich ist auch gift also würde ich
nicht empfehlen
und da es gibt dieses den verrückten
eismacher gleich haben sie auch so ein
händler
aber das würde dann auch wie keinen fall
probieren jeden fall am ende stirbt er
und man erfährt angeblich was über die
praktische also wie das praktisch
abgelaufen ist
indem wir die ganze geschichte erfahren
also wer anwesen war
platon war nicht anwesend also der
hauptfigur sagt ich denke plattform war
krank und deswegen nicht war nicht da
randbemerkung man man überlegt
vielleicht haben uns also man fragt sich
ob akten so wie wir uns schon gefragt
haben
inwiefern die sie diese sokratische
dialoge wirklich akkurate darstellungen
sind wie sie wirklich waren was er
gesagt hat
und also wer argumentiert hat also
inwiefern wir hier den historischen
krise wirklich erleben und zum beispiel
also dass die frage kann man sehr gut
bei der apologie stellen
es ist mein war das wirklich die rede
die softies gehalten hat beim prozess wo
er verurteilt würde wissen wir natürlich
nicht aber wenn plattform dann
beschreibt genau wie es war in der
letzten szene also in den in der letzten
stunde das leben des sockels und dann
sagt er ausdrücklich ich war nicht dabei
dann also ist das ein man könnte
überlegen was will platon da erreichen
mein verlag war wirklich krank also ganz
banale erklärung er war krank
wenn etwas weniger banal er will sich
entschuldigen dafür dass er nicht dabei
war
also er will allen anderen sagen hey ich
war nicht er wird dass sie nicht dabei
war vielleicht wie ein skandal dass er
nicht dabei war
er sagt ja ich war krank also deswegen
habe ich meine hausaufgaben nicht
gemacht so in der art
oder vielleicht das ist interessant ich
vielleicht will er irgendwie
problematisieren die die beziehungen
verwies produzieren zwischen dem was wir
lesen und dem was wirklich stattgefunden
hat das wäre auch interessant ist
praktisch ein zeichen das nicht zu ernst
zu nehmen als darstellung von der
historischen dem historischen ergebnis
weiß man nichts auf jeden fall erfahren
wir dass socke thüs lang auf seinen tod
warten musste weil man niemand also
leute die unter todesurteil waren
dürften nicht umgebracht werden werden
eines religiösen festes und uns also im
detail geht es um einen shift schiff von
tc sus der den männern gebracht hat also
der das schiff muss vor allem und dann
zurück und während der schifffahrt ist
darf man den verhalten nicht hinrichten
deswegen wartet erst erlernen auf seinen
tod
wir wissen aus der erfahrung ist
wirklich wahr ist wieder es ist wieder
eine interessante frage aber es gibt
einen zweiten dialog namens creed on wo
sein freund dieses freuen triton kommen
zu ihm und sagt ich habe die den wächter
bezahlt und er lässt sich frei und wir
haben freunde und wir sind bereit ich
aus athen zu nehmen damit dufry wirst
also du kannst sicher
diese todes und dieses todesurteil
entkommen
und dann findet ein langes gespräch
statt wo krieg an und sagte diese sich
darüber unterhalten unterhalten ob das
an ihm ist dass er wegläuft
rostock ots bericht fertig dass er nicht
weg laufen soll
zum beispiel dadurch dass die dass er
bürger hat hens ist und dass er die
gesetze athens unterstützen muss als
bürger teams auch wenn sie unrecht
vorgehen kritisch sagt ja warum warum
muss die ungerechte gesetze verteidigen
oder unterstützen oder folgen hin und
her hin und her auf jeden fall am ende
beschließt sollten sie es dass er
bleiben soll und dann also man kann
sagen es gibt apologie dann kriegt dann
weiter und das ist die historische
reihenfolge dazu könnte man auch andere
dialoge tun zum beispiel täters und
kreuze front also bitte in bei in dem
auto von ist es so dass lokatis auf den
weg ins gericht erst um verklagt zu
werden und dann begegnet er jemanden
namens waterfront und dann haben sie ein
gespräch also viele dialoge sind in
diesem zeitraum gesetzt
das könnte also fand plattform
interessant als eine dramatische lage
oder zusammenhang für seine dialoge auf
jeden fall
er läuft nicht weg dann kommen die
freunde rhein und seine frau sein tipp
sockel dieses frau xanthippe und die
kinder sind da und so ein tipp schreit
und fängt an zu weinen weil es so zornig
ist das sollte diesen nie seine freunde
wiedersehen werden wird und sorgen sagt
bach gottschick sie ihre ausbeute
und damit sind die weibliche wesen
entfernt
das ist wird oft als eine berühmte zähne
für die antike einstellung frauen
gegenüber genommen also es gibt
philosophie und frauen und keine
mischung müssen wir natürlich nicht
unterstützen
aber das ist eine sehr auffällige szene
die die frau dann praktisch immer
einstellen sie vor ihren mann wird
hingerichtet und er sagt du störst mich
ich will mit meinem kumpel treten also
wirklich so etwas abläuft
ok und dann schwenkt socket dies mit den
freunden an über ein sehr dringendes
thema zu diskutieren nämlich ob man
erwarten kann dass man körperlichen tod
überleben kann
es spricht ob man erwarten kann dass die
seele weiterlebt nachdem man stirbt das
ist die frage des dialogs und dass das
will ich wirklich betonen weil unter
philosophen ist das berühmteste an den
pfeilern nichts dass es was mit der
zelle zu tun hat sondern dass man hier
in diesen dialog die beste erklärung hat
warum wir an die ideen glauben sollten
also die der bayern wird immer genommen
aus praktischen der text der text lecken
für die ideen werde und ich will
wirklich also was ich betonen will in
diesen zwei vorlesungen also heute und
dann nächste woche ist dass dieser
dialog nichts nicht die ideen werde im
vordergrund hat vielmehr wird die ideen
eingebracht um seine theorie über die
seele zu begründen nicht umgekehrt
und wenn dann könnte man sogar sagen
dass die ideen er selbst nichts bewiesen
wird also er argumentiert nicht dafür
sondern nimmt praktisch an dass es die
ideen gibt und dann zum beispiel das
erste mal dass er die ideen erwähnt ist
sagt sorg hieß wir also er und seine
freunde wir sind wir haben die
gewohnheit über die ideen zu sprechen
also gerechtigkeit an sich oder
tapferkeit an sich was auch immer und da
wir diese ideen postulieren können wir
davon ausgehen dass bla bla bla bla bla
und das bla bla bla bla bla ist ein
argument für die unsterblichkeit der
seele
also man kann sagen dass die idee wäre
schon eine rolle spielt aber nur um
unsterblichkeit der seele zu begründen
und nicht umgekehrt
allerdings gibt es eine passage die ich
nächste woche besprechen werde
wo sollte dies schildert wie er als
junger mann
welche überlegungen er als junger mann
gemacht hat die ihn so dieser ideen
lehre geführt haben
also noch mal muss man hier vorsichtig
sein wir wissen eigentlich nicht ob der
historische socket sokratis wirklich
eine idee hatte und wenn nicht dann ist
das alles irgendwie von platon erfunden
also er tut seine eigene ideen lehre in
den mund von sokratis als ob das eine
autobiografische darstellung ist wieso
katies zu dieser lehre gekommen ist und
das würdige plattform eigentlich zu
zahlen
das zu tun aber wissen wir eben nichts
also die die was ich dann machen wir
weit war ich so überzeugt bin dass die
unsterblichkeit der seele wirklich hier
im mittelpunkt steht
ich will heute die unsterblichkeit frage
besprechen und dann nächste woche werden
wir dann tiefer die formen oder ideen
betrachten
allerdings wie sie heute sehen werden
gibt es dann argumente für die
unsterblichkeit die derselbe die die
ideen der voraussetzungen also die ideen
wenn eine rolle spielen
fast bei allen argumenten also der oder
zwei von den hauptargumenten die
sogenannte affinität argument und die
das wiedererkennungs argument die haben
beide mit den ideen zu tun
vielleicht so ist vielleicht soll ich
sagen es gibt drei hauptargumente die
ich besprechen will
das erste ass des gegensatz argument
zweite ist wieder der regierung wieder
erinnerung
es wäre schön gewesen wenn deutsch
das deutsche wort verbitterung neigt
dazu sagen wäre zum beispiel die
kollektion
und dann der phoenix argument das sind
die drei das ist zu sagen müssen unser
plan für heute und die sind alle
argumente für existenz der seele oder
bzw für die unsterblichkeit der seele
bevor wir daran gehen wollte ich schnell
eine umfrage machen wie viele leute hier
würden sagen dass sie eine seele haben
überlegen das kommt nicht auf die
steuererklärung
aber es geht um philosophie und deswegen
ist sehr wichtig also überlegen habe ich
eine seele
und wenn ja sollen sie die hand hoch
halten und sehr hoch war nicht schlecht
und wer ist überzeugt dass er oder sie
keine seele besitzt viel weniger beliebt
da sind dass das interessant und wer ist
nichts sicher
und wer es nicht sicher ob er oder sie
sicher ist
und so weiter also dass die drei sind
die skeptiker also die antike skeptiker
zu sagen dass ich sicher bin dass ich
uns sicher bin werde übertrieben
ok also da es so viele anhänger der der
seele oder erzählen tätig ergibt will
ich fragen warum sie so überzeugt sind
dass sie eine seele haben
beziehungsweise was sie und überhaupt
unter seele verstehen also was sind sie
was ist ihre begründung nochmal wer sagt
dass er oder sie eine seele hat wäre zu
sagen ist eine eine begründung zu geben
für diese überzeugung
okay das ist interessant dass sie würden
sagen ja meine seele ist unsterblich und
deswegen muss ich doch eine seele haben
ohne zu existieren könnte das ist also
das ist schon interessant dass man
sozusagen mit dem mit dem nachleben
anfang und also wir haben mindestens im
fernsehen leichen gesehen und die seinen
nicht sehr lebhaft zu sein
und weil wir überzeugt sind dass wir
doch nach dem tod nach leben wollen wir
glauben mindestens dass es eine seele
gibt so ist dass die überlegung aber ist
das meer eine hoffnung oder eine
überzeugung etwas mehr wie eine hoffnung
also wenn ich keine seele habe dann
werde ich wirklich sterben und das war
schlecht also sowas wie war waren glaube
ich dass meine frau nicht fremd geht ja
weiß so schlimm wäre
und deswegen kann es doch nicht sein
also dass das ist das ist natürlich
keine philosophische begründung das ist
nur eine eine hoffen aber vielleicht
meinen sie es gibt andere grund zu
glauben dass man überlebt
was haben sie gelesen also den pfeilern
gene also sie sind von diesen argumenten
überzeugt so viele sowieso geht nicht
warum glaubt warum glauben sie ex weil
die plattform gelesen aber das gilt
immer also eine sehr gute begründung
gut also dass würde ich die begründung
durch einheit also die idee ist es muss
irgendwas geben was mein körper
vielleicht oder was meinem körper ein
highlight und nicht der körper selbst
war der grip ist also es sind nur teile
oder man könnte vielleicht auch sogar
sagen warum ist dieser körper nicht um
angriffe dieser körper mein körper weil
dieser körper von meiner seele
organisiert ist und diese nicht dieser
nicht zum beispiel
mit jedem genutzt
ok also die rede ist dass die serie
praktisch das lebensprinzip erst für als
lebende würden sie deswegen sagen dass
andere lebewesen auch zellen besitzen
zum beispiel hunde und sonnenblumen
nochmal das heißt nicht dass sie dass
sie eine wortmeldung haben müssen man
wer glaubt dass es nur interesse wer
glaubt noch mal dass sie er oder sie
eine seele hat und wer glaubt dass von
ihnen nach handy hoch immer noch ja weil
die überzeugt wir haben handy hoch danke
ok und hans runter wenn sie nicht
glauben dass tiere eine seele haben also
wenn sie glauben dass nur menschen
wieder die
wieder die hände hoch wenn wenn sie eine
seele haben
okay wer von ihnen glaubt dass kunde
zellen haben dialogen lassen denn hunde
eine seele haben also mehr als die
hälfte
und was ist mit pflanzen also sie sehen
das ist ein problem und interessante
oder also wir haben praktisch vier
gruppen
sie können jetzt haben wir vier gruppen
hier diejenigen die kein land keine
seele klagen diejenige die nur für
menschen eine zelle zu lassen würden
diejenigen die denken menschen und tiere
schon aber platz pflanzen nicht und dann
diejenigen die sagen alle lebewesen
haben sie übrigens für pflanzen nicht
gut das war konsequent von ihnen das ist
immer gut wenn die studenten sich nicht
widerlegen
solches zeug nachfragen
also ich wollte eigentlich die frag
nicht sein aber das ist eine
interessante frage noch mal wechseln und
dann hören wir auf mit dem gibt es auch
andere fragen gingen jemand die meinung
wer wird die waren größere tange werden
unterstützt nochmal leute die gesagt
haben dass es keine serien gibt die sind
jetzt erleichtert
die müssen wir da sitzen
wer von ihnen glaubt dass es nur eine
seele gibt die wir alle teilen
weil das ist nicht sehr beliebt
also ich glaube die meisten anhänger der
seltenere denken für jeden eine serie
eine mischung stimmen wir nicht ab also
was ist die mischung
die seele und wieder okay also es gibt
eine zelle und dann haben wir so
genannte teils allen das ist das ist die
überzeugung die man bei noris muss
findet platonischer in der spätantike
daten genau dass es gibt szenen mit
großem herz wobei deutsch das in ein
großes aber es sei auf englisch wäre es
ein größeres und diese ganz zelle wird
dann also wir haben an dieser stelle
teilen würde ich sagen übrigens klar
tonnen platin ihr habt nicht geschrieben
aber in einem anderen dialog namens team
behauptet platon dass die welt eine
serie hat oder das universum also die
die neue platte hätten gesagt es gibt
viele schlechthin und dann gibt es all
diese körper und die körper
einschließlich die welt haben alle teile
diese seele also die haben alle an
dieser stelle teil
und dann gibt es einfach sehr schlecht
hin also was genau die beziehung ist
zwischen teil zählen und bis am zelle
ist unklar
bei den linken aber das ist auf jeden
fall was sie gedacht haben
also diese diese idee das ist er
wirklich ein lebendes prinzip ist das
ist der aristotelischen sind alle posten
tätig
gratuliere ja es gibt schlimmere sachen
sein als alles hell ist und also das ist
wie wir später sehen werden das ist
wirklich sein anfangspunkt visa sehr
sagt alle stimmen zu dass die zelle ein
lebensprinzip ist dann was können wir
daraus schließen dass ist praktisch
seine vorgehensweise
den smarten lebt diese treten
um eine ethische essenz dieses
beinhaltet
rösler nachricht schon weiter ist es
dann wirklich um an die aktualisierte
spielen
und eigentlich also das ist was ich als
erster begründung erwartet habe aus der
aus dem publikum
also ich habe erwartet dass jemand
sofort sagen würde ich kann nicht sehen
wie mein körper einfach allein also nur
mein körper denken kann wurde bewusst
sein kann und deswegen bin ich überzeugt
dass ich eine serie habe bei körper sind
tot so sagen oder sie sind tot klingt
also das mit leben zu tun hat da körper
können nicht denken
nur selten können denken und deswegen
brauchen wir nicht nur einen körper
sondern eine seele
das bringt seele ist sehr eng mit geist
zusammen
und hier möchte ich wirklich betonen
dass es eine große unterschied gibt es
einen großen unterschied gibt zwischen
antiken zellen werde und der jetzigen
philosophie des geistes also was auf
englisch voraus wir meint heißt also
wenn mein geist ist ein schwieriges wort
weil es das hat kenianische unterton
was passt nie wirklich nützlich ist
aber wenn man geist aus meint versteht
also im geist nur aus prinzip des
denkens und bewusstseins und dann sieht
man sofort dass das ist ihr kommt was
ich selber sagen wollte alles schön dass
jedes gesagt haben ein lebendes prinzip
ist nicht dasselbe wie ein geist und das
sieht man sehr gut an den bereichen die
wir gerade hatten nämlich pflanzen und
tiere weil diejenigen die die gesagt
haben dass pflanzenzellen haben
ich gehe davon aus dass sie nicht
behaupten dass pflanzen denken oder oder
es jemand hier bereits zu sagen dass
pflanzen denken ja wirklich oder warum
nicht sie sind sich sicher dass sie
nicht sicher sind
bewusst seien
nochmal was meinen sie würden es nicht
ausschließen oder sie wirklich weil sie
zum beispiel mit dem irgendwann
reagieren
dagegen trainiert hat und wird diesen
texten oder könnt ihr richtig sein oder
die pflanzen verschwörung gegen die
menschen
das ergibt
die genug lieben andere gewesen andere
flieger kommen
die tabakpflanze also dass es stimmt
dass tabak gefährlich ist
ja ok trotzdem muss man muss man also
natürlich interessant und wenn man wenn
man bereit ist bewusstsein pflanzen
zuzuschreiben
dann kommen die sachen wieder zusammen
also immer in ihre begründen warum
pflanzen bewusst sind ist fast als ob
sie sagen ja die machens diese lebens
aktivitäten
immerhin sie sind fähig zum beispiel
reagieren oder miteinander zu reden und
das ist eine art beeindruckende art zu
leben zu sagen und das ist so
beeindruckend dass wir wir werden
vielleicht bereit das bewusstsein zu
nennen
aber dann kommen bewusst sein und neben
einfach zusammen
aber mein punkt war dass die meisten
leute würden wahrscheinlich sagen dass
tiere und menschen bewusst sind pflanzen
nichts aber alle sind bereit zu sagen
dass pflanzen leben das ist nicht
kontrovers übrigens gibt es natürlich
auch philosophen die denken dass gleich
nichts heutzutage aber es hat alles
gegeben die nicht die dir aber zur
überzeugung man dass pflanzen nicht
bewusst sind und nichts erleben können
zum beispiel descartes beweise hat war
der überzeugung dass pflanzen der geht
nur maschinen dass tiere also
nichtmenschliche tiere nur maschinen
sind und kein inneres leben haben weil
er so überzeugt so sagen dass die zellen
nur geist ist und deswegen es gibt ganz
schlimme sachen bei der cargo erst zum
beispiel solcher ist interessanter als
wenn man ein tier gequält einen tierwelt
es ist das als ob sie schmerzempfinden
die die können das nachahmen so gut ist
wirklich erstaunlich
und das würde ich sogar aus bereich
fertigung für die experimente genutzt
benutzt also diese dieses argument das
tier in keiner das leben haben auf jeden
fall an ich würde diese zwei
begründungen für die serie ist sehr
stark unterscheiden
und dann würde ich sagen es ist wofür
unseres verständnis der antiken zellen
lehre entscheiden entscheidend dass
partners orten ist und all die nachfolge
die verstehen zelle indes nicht als
geist sondern als lebensprinzip und
geist wird vor allem bei der socgen ist
auch bei fahrten zu treffen geist ist
dann nur eine fähigkeit die man der
seele zu schreiben und vielleicht nicht
allen zellen sondern nur menschlich ist
die nur der menschlichen seele
ok hat hat jemand andere begründungen
warum er oder sie an sehr glatt die
seele glaubt bevor wir weiter gehen
natürlich gibt es gibt das ist fakt dass
sie das gefragt haben das ist mein leib
nächste das immer so schön wenn die
studenten genau das fragen was sie
gerade sagen wollte ist als ob sie
eingepflanzt werden sozusagen also die
zwei euro kriegen sie später
die frage ist muss man an die
unsterblichkeit der seele glauben
um an die serie so glauben natürlich
nichts also man zum beispiel
man könnte sagen ja ich den lebens ich
bin bewusst kann denken ich bin eine
einheits deswegen glaube ich dass das
eigentlich eine seele habe aber ich
glaube nicht dass meine seel überlebt
weil diese szene abhängig ist von den
körper also ohne meinen körper kann
meine serie weiter existieren
sie braucht den körper um weiter
existieren und wofür ich das sagen
wollte ist dass das die frage des
wetters
die freude des scheiterns ist nicht ob
wir eine seele haben sondern auch die
seele die wir natürlich haben ohne
sterblich ist er hat es gesagt er geht
einfach davon aus dass menschen eine
serie besitzen das kommt eigentlich
nicht in frage
die frage die erst dann stellt ist
angenommen es gibt seele und körper
was ist dann gebietet die beziehung
zwischen diesen zwei entitäten ist es so
dass sie sich gegenseitig beeinflussen
und der der eine kann nur existieren mit
dem anderen zusammen
oder ist es so dass man
wenn man stirbt so körper weg seele ist
unberührt und mein körper ist weg kein
problem
oder vielleicht geht die seele hin sogar
in einen neuen körper dass es gibt
körper 1 und dann körper zwei wurden
nachdem dieser körper ausstirbt bewegt
die seele die die gleiche säle in diesem
zweiten körper das ist soeben ein
fleischer und diese überzeugung findet
man dann am ende des booms also das
sagte thies dass das brave menschen
werden dann als tier wiedergeboren
zum beispiel werden gewalttätige
menschen als wolf widder geboren und
nicht philosophen die sehr gehorsam und
brav sind werden an ameisen zum beispiel
also seien sie froh dass sie es für die
machen
sie haben eine chance wieder ein mensch
zu sein
dass der geist menschen so stark dass
wir jetzt noch nicht klar dass worden
was hier genau wie der markt
jede strecke ja danke übrigens die also
sie also ihr punkt ist denn die zählen
nicht der geistes dann weiß ich noch
nicht was diese erst überhaupt genau
also dass das ist eben die frage und
also ich sehe den weiteren so dass uns
beide sorten ist es noch klarer der fall
dass sie haben dieses bild
es gibt seele und körper und das ist
sozusagen kommt nichts kontrovers dass
ein mensch aus seele und körper
irgendwie besteht weil heben ist nicht
kontrovers ist dass wir leben cent in
die zelle ist nicht mehr und nicht
weniger aus ein lebensprinzip also eine
seele findet man jedes mal dass man
leben
sid die frage ist dann was das ist was
ist es das den körper leben verleiht
und das ist kontrovers also die die
ganze frage ist was was welche andere
eigenschaften die serie hat zum beispiel
ist die seele und körperlich und
vielleicht würden sie jetzt sagen was
natürlich ist körperlich weil wir haben
die ganze zeit gesagt es gibt seele und
körper und die sind nicht derselbe aber
und übrigens dass das hier dieses bild
das wirklich dualismus nennen also
dualismus ist die idee dass ein mensch
aus zwei metaphysisch und verschiedenen
aspekten oder teile besteht
normalerweise wenn wir über dual is muss
heutzutage sprechen wir meinen damit
wieder descartes für meinen
katalanisches tourismus und das ist
journalismus von von geist und körper
also wenn jemand also wenn sie bei den
bucks of fire sind und niemand sagt
vielleicht nach drei oder vier pferde
zugibt dass er journalist ist was er
wahrscheinlich damit sagende ist dass
die ist dass er der überzeugung ist dass
er einen körper ist mit einem geist und
dass dieser geist im material ist ja das
ist wahrscheinlich was jahre und der
dualismus verstehen oder aber ich würde
sagen tourismus ist eigentlich ein
erstes kann man mindestens als in einer
mit einer allgemeineren bedeutung nehmen
und tourismus werde nur zu sagen es gibt
körper und dann noch ein prinzip in uns
und dieses prinzip kann man definieren
wie man will ist es aber nicht mein
körper zum beispiel könnte es ein
zweiter körper sein instrument und die
diese vorstellung wird ausdrücklich
erwähnt in dem veit sorger thies fragt
seine freunde ob sie vielleicht weil ihm
ein dramatischen läuft es so ab dass die
freunde sagen warum das hast du keinen
nicht hast du nicht angst zu sterben das
sagt ja aber überzeugt bin dass ich
weiterleben werde die sie gesagt haben
und sie sagen ja das ist vielleicht ein
bisschen unhöflich unter diesen
umständen aber dass du sicher dass du
das überlebt und dann sagte er ja gut
die frage der sollen wir besprechen und
zum und so verbringen sie die letzten
die letzte stunde seines lebens mit
dieser überlegung ob die seele wirklich
gebunden
überlebt oder nichts und ein verdacht
was sie vielleicht haben sagt sorry es
ist dass die zelle
sowas ist wie luft oder auch was
vielleicht wegbläst sobald sein körper
stimmt und diese idee ist deutsch ist
dass die zelle eine ein feiner und
subtilere körper ist innerhalb des
gesamt körpers und das ist genau was
viele postkarte gedacht haben dass die
zelle aus feuer besteht oder aus luft
oder was auch immer wie wir gesehen
haben in der ersten vorlesung und das
will er wieder legen wird zeigen nicht
dass diese existiert sondern dass die
sally materiell erst das ist sein ziel
und nicht nur materiell sondern immer
das material und natürlich käfig und
unsterblich was wollten sie fragen
zusammenhang die also das wird in dem
fall nicht thematisiert aber in der
politik
es gibt es gibt eine unterscheidung die
man oft zwischen das ist natürlich ein
anderer dialog von platon und auch start
und in der polit er das ist sein
berühmtester werk ja und hier behauptet
er dass die zelle aus drei teilen
besteht nämlich rationelle seele also
die denkt seele und dann zwei weitere
zellen die anscheinend die emotionen
dann besitzen das werden wir sehen in
zwei wochen
und oft wird hat man die vermutung das
klarstellen er hier sicher entwickelt
hat also in weiter denkt er okay es gibt
diese einheitliche säle womit wir leben
und denken und weiter dran denkt ja
eigentlich nichts aber dann später wird
er überzeugt dass er eine komplexere
theorie braucht wo die seele aus drei
aspekte oder teile besteht und die
untere teil sind dann für die emotionen
zuständig im allgemeinen übrigen das
könnte man sagen wenn man dieses bild
hat seele körper also die realistische
bild dann haben wir all diese
fähigkeiten es gibt all diese
erscheinungen in unserem leben und
sofort kann man sich die frage stellen
welche aspekte der menschlichen natur
oder welche fähigkeiten welche
erlebnisse sollen wir der seele zu
schreiben welche dem körper zum beispiel
dass jemand mich sehen kann also das ist
sichtbar sind ist offensichtlich
hat offensichtlich mit dem körper zu tun
nicht mit der seele also niemanden würde
ich ja sagen dass er oder sie meine
seele jetzt sehen kann
und wenn ich eine seele haben habe dann
ist es relativ und konsums dass ich
damit denke aber fast alles andere in
der mitte ist dann schwierig zum
beispiel die emotionen oder lust zu
empfinden oder schmerz zu empfinden und
in der geschichte der philosophie
insgesamt aber vor allem in der antiken
und mittelalterlichen positiv sieht man
immer wieder unsicherheit und streit
darüber was man den körper zu schreiben
soll und was man der seele zu schreiben
soll also schmerz zum beispiel ist ein
sehr gutes beispiel
schmerzempfinden als wenn ich
schmerzempfinden ist das eine
erscheinung die in meinem körper
stattfindet und dann wird meine serie
irgendwie bewusst dass mein körper das
ist meinem körper weh tut irgendwie oder
es ist mehr dass irgendwas dass mein
körper irgendetwas erlebt aber mein
körper nichts an sich nicht spielen kann
und meine seele muss dann
schmerzempfinden und das ist wirklich
kontrovers oder anderes beispiel sind
die emotionen in den körper oder in den
geist seele und wieder gibt es dann
kontrovers darüber aber anscheinend
hatten hier im weitern noch nicht dran
gedacht dass es hier ein problem gibt
mit emotionen und der seele später denkt
er dran und um das zu erklären muss er
dann eine dreiteilige seele dann kosten
nur eine seele ja ja ja ja antiken
philosophie schon
diese änderung 14
auslesen lassen also fern dass es mit
ihm verwendeten worden also ein ganzes
gesehen wird ja in meinen also ich
glaube also eine sache ist dass sie
einfach ein wort dafür haben also psyche
ist das wort werde ich vielleicht
vorhersagen sagen wovon werde natürlich
das wort psychologie manchmal hat man in
diesem zusammenhang das wort psychologie
für diesen bereich der philosophie also
psychologie ist den antiken platz wie es
nicht psychologie wir verstehen dass es
allen terry oder sowas und dieses wort
befindet man befindet sich bei home er
uns unsere in athen und leipzig die
philosophen fühlten sich unter druck zu
erkennen was das ist mit zu überlegen ob
es ist so eine was es ist oder was sie
ist es ist eine erklärung vielleicht
aber ich glaube die andere erklärung ist
wie wir stürzen immer sofort auf die ein
verdacht dass sie an geist denken war
das ist woran wir denken wenn wir an
diese bedenken und wir vergessen dass
für sie habe ich allerdings schon gesagt
aber das deutlich nach mal weil es
wichtig ist meiner meinung nach die
denken hauptsächlich ein lebensprinzip
und deswegen ist es wie gesagt
offensichtlich das ist eine seele gibt
es leben gibt und dann könnte man so
sehen matti realistisch sein
wenn man dann eine materialistische
erklärung für serie hat zum beispiel
auch dance luft vor er das auch immer
sauber also es gibt all diese theorien
die platten hier bewerfen de das ist
sein ziel
in den federn
ok so sollen wir ein paar argumente
jetzt oder nicht ein paar 3d betrachten
also wie er das beweisen will
ok also das erste was wir betrachten
sollen ist das gegensatz argument und
hier ist des arguments neverwinter
folgendes
okay die die behauptung ist wenn wir in
der welt veränderungen erleben was wir
erleben ist immer dass irgendwas von
zuerst nicht passt oder das ist zuerst
coupé ausschließt und dann geht es den
kay zb kalt und warm also warm sein
schließt kalt sein aus und wenn wir
sagen dass irgendwas waren wird dann
setzen wir voraus dass dieses ding
vorher relativ kalt war vielleicht nicht
der krieg als aber kälter als es wird
weil wenn wir sagen ja es war warm und
dann wird es genauso war dann sollen wir
uns denn zum beispiel wenn sie sagen ja
der tag gestern war 21 grad
heute ist ein grad wieder sie würde
nicht sagen es ist warm ist es waren
geworden
sie würden sagen dass es warm geblieben
und das ist keine keine veränderung das
ist der punkt es keine veränderung
ok also ist nämlich nicht kontrovers was
dann kontrovers ist wie er das für die
unsterblichkeit der seele benutzt er
sagt das sterben
hier ist eine veränderung können wir
auch zustimmen glaube ich und was ist
das für eine eine veränderung
zuerst ist man am leben oder leben dann
ist man tot
also genau wie genau wie ein stein zum
beispiel von kalt zu warm gehen kann
muss es irgendwas geben was zuerst
lebend ist und dann tot
und das ist die seele man könnte sich
fragen hey wollte er nicht heute nicht
zeigen dass die zelle unsterblich ist
also wie kann er dann sagen dass die
select ote wird antwort unter todt
versteht er die trennung zwischen seele
und körper also was er es was das dann
heißt es
zusammen mit dem körper und getrennt von
dem körper ist genau das was diese
veränderungen erlebt
das ist zuerst mit danone ist körper und
übrigens muss es sein das war eine sorge
die die freunde haben ist was es wenn du
stirbst aber nie wieder lebst ist
sozusagen also wer zusammen zurückkommen
können
antwort ja es muss so sein weil das
wasser ist wieder cool werden
also das war es wieder kalt werden warum
stellen wir vor dass sachen von kalt zu
warm werden würden würden aber nie aber
es würde nie ein look ergeben
dann würde am ende alles warm sein das
muss ein das wird auch manchmal eines
zyklus argument genannt also die idee
ist dass wenn man nicht von q super
super super gehen würde es ein zyklus
dann werde alles am ende einfach p und
hier würde das heißen dass alle alles am
ende würde sterben oder tot sein und es
würde ihn kein leben existieren das ist
das argument haben
okay das ist mehr oder weniger was sie
sagt ich würde sagen dass diese argument
verblüffend und plausibel scheint oder
mein system ist jemand der antwort an
den augen und sie sind beeindruckt ja
okay ist eines von 100
warum sind sie beeindruckt
logische schon gibt vielleicht
vielleicht sollten wir überlegen warum
es nicht aber die meisten der leute sind
nicht überzeugt oder ist jemand
überzeugt okay was was fällt dann an dem
argument ein was ist das problem wenn
sie ist nicht überzeugend ist was daran
ist nicht überzeugend zurückzulegen und
wird sind wir überhaupt kein leben
ergeben
das kann ja auch sein dass immer wenn
ein neuer mensch geworden wird es auch
eine neue seele
hier entsteht ja okay also die die
annahme dass nicht alle das gehört haben
sagt er macht die annahme dass man
nichts zu sagen hier hier verantworten
könnte also plötzlich taucht eine seele
auf und ersetzt die andere sein die
gestorben sind dass sich eine idee und
das denken es ist nichts was alles tot
wird am ende weil neue serien kommen
immer wieder und werden immer wieder tot
ja
[Musik]
wenn sie überlegen kann sowas zu diesem
punkt sagen
also ich denke ein ein problem und das
würde übrigens in der antike gesagt dass
sie tätig sind sie jetzt bereit
schießen sie los also das sind zweifel
sorgen also eine sorge ist vielleicht
kommen kommen immer wieder neue rein und
hier sorge ist ja vielleicht ist doch
wirklich so schlimm
die weltkriegs jahre hier und nach 2x
jahre ist alles tot
aber wir sind noch nicht so weit also
vielleicht haben eine gute antwort dazu
hätte weiß ich nichts man könnte
vielleicht an meinen wenn man annimmt
dass das universum ewig ist dann hätte
man die antwort auf der hand und das ist
was soll ich sagen könnte
er sollte dieses überzeugt dass die welt
tätig ist und deswegen kann er sagen ja
warten schon eine ewigkeit derzeit also
alles was ablaufen kann werde schon
abgelaufen also wenn es kein zyklus gibt
nicht dass er dieses argument
unterstützen würde aber wenn man
ewigkeit der welt ausgewiesen mit diesem
argument aus platten kombiniert kann
dann kann man diese
was ich sagen wollte ist dass ein
aristotelische philosoph in der antike
hat sich infolge weise beklagt über
dieses argument er gesagt das problem
ist dass plattform im tod als trennung
von körper aber was wir wirklich
fürchten ist nicht trennung von körper
es ist nicht existenz also mein nicht
also wenn du nicht bist und p nicht
gepresst
das kann man zweierlei verstehen kann
entweder eine positive eigenschaft sein
vasco ausschließt oder oder es könnte
einfach die abwesenheit des qs bedeuten
zum beispiel wenn jemand sagt dass die
farbe blau nichts heute krank ist
komisch vielleicht könnte man vielleicht
nach sieben wäre beim vatertagsfest die
fahrräder es häufig krank wenn das
stimmt warum ja weißt nicht weil die
farbe blau heute so gesund ist sondern
weil die eigenschaft krankheit einfach
nicht passend ist für die farbe blau und
ähnlicher weise könnte man hier sagen
was ich unter todt verstehe es nicht
ein anderer zustand was die seele haben
kann sondern einfach nicht existenz wo
es überhaupt keine eigenschaften haben
kann also was was passiert wenn man
stirbt ist nicht dass man zuerst dass
die zelle zu erleben ist und dann tot
ist also zuerst zusammen mit dem körper
und dann getan von dem körper was diese
realität ist wenn nicht schon und wenn
es vernichtet wird
dann gibt es als
nichts also dann gibt es nichts mehr
weil es den zieht vernichtet würde ja ja
und
es ist im moment
ja es gibt eine sehr schöne stelle am
ende des leidens wissen durch all diese
argumente gegangen und dann sagt sagen
die freunde sollte diese was sollen
sollen hier mit dir machen nachdem du
gestorben ist
also nachdem du den gift getrunken hast
und dann sagt er
denn wenn ihr mich fangen könnte dann
für glück damit aber was sie mit meinem
körper machen das liegt bei euch wissen
wir ist mir egal
genau und das ist ein wichtiger punkt
die den wir noch nichts besprochen haben
wobei also jemand hat gesagt dass die
serie unsere einheits anbietet und dass
es zu dieser idee dass seele hätte hätte
man vielleicht sagen können am anfang
als ich gefragt habe was es welche
begründungen haben wir für die serie
wir könnten sagen es gibt eine frage der
identität was was bin ich eigentlich bin
ich mein körper oder sonst irgendwas und
wenn es sonst irgendwas dann vielleicht
meine seele und sage dies ist auf jeden
fall der überzeugung dass erst wie
diesen das sei und nichts sein körper
und auch nicht das ganze also es nicht
er ist nicht das zusammengesetztes aus
serien körper er ist nur seine seele wie
wir weiter sorglos sein werden ist hdj
ließ anscheinend der meinung dass ein
mensch das gesamte erst also wir sind
nicht nur die seele sondern eine delta
körper das ist was ein mensch ist haben
wollten sie wissen
und draußen
ja schon aber dass es irgendwann mit den
preisen
haben sie das
erklären dass sie
der grund dafür
leben ist
er ist eigentlich wie ihr punkt glaube
ich das vielleicht nach dieser zeit
würde alles zurückkehren
denn alles zurückkehrt aber wir haben
nicht die zeit erlebt dagegen könnte es
sein dass wir das einfach noch nichts
bordeaux kommt nicht wieder
es ist einfach weg ja es gibt es gibt es
übrigens hier ein sehr grundlegendes
problem was man vielleicht über leicht
übersieht nämlich die frage ob die welt
als solche sich entwickelt also
natürlich entwickelt die welt
irgendjemand sie waren also heute in der
flur haben sie alle haben sie alle
hoffentlich ein bisschen weniger über
plattform gewürzt aus jetzt zum beispiel
also es gibt veränderung und entwicklung
aber im großen und ganzen nichts als die
welt war immer mehr oder weniger so wie
sie ist und je nachdem wie man im großen
ganzen versteht könnte das stimmen oder
nicht also sind zum beispiel würden wir
vielleicht sagen das universum hat immer
die gleichen naturgesetze ihm von daher
ist die welt ändern so wie es war
aber er sollte dies zum beispiel würde
was viel stärkeres sagen er würde sagen
die das universum dass wir sehen ist
sowie es so wie es jetzt ist so war es
immer und das betrifft zb welche tiere
und pflanzen spezies es gibt es gab
immer grafen und affen und hunde und
blabla weil er natürlich anteil wird ist
nicht glaubt also die das wort die welt
es für ihn sehr stabil das alles immer
dasselbe und vielleicht vielleicht wenn
man diese annahme markt ist dieses
zyklus argumente ein bisschen überzeugen
ok ich wollte jetzt zum zweiten
augenmerk kommen das ist die niederung
argument und dass wir uns daran erinnern
was wir in den männern gesehen habe
übrigens dieser städte dieses sehr
schwacher witz ist auch bei platon zu
finden
er ist dass wir diese gewohnheit haben
über die ideen zu sprechen und dass wir
an wieder helle und glauben und dann
sagte eine davon aber das ist mir ein
bisschen unscharf im internet kannst du
uns daran erinnern
super lustig also und dann haben hier
diese passage das gehört zu den
berühmtesten passagen platons das ist
ein bisschen unübersichtlicher als wir
bei den männern gefunden haben weil
männer ist sozusagen wie ein
theaterstück würde es gestörter
geschrieben also das heißt männern sagt
irgendwas ändern sagte sagt irgendwas
aber hier ist der ganzen dialog wird
wieder erzählt von jemand der da was zu
einem freund es gibt sogenannte das
sogenannte rahmen für den dialog und
dann alles was im gefängnis
stattgefunden hat wird als laufender
laufen der erzählung erzählt in der
polit er zum beispiel erzählt soccer
teams selbst über ein gespräch das er
hatte mit anderen und deswegen sagt ja
ständig und dann sagte ich bei blei und
dann sagte glauben sie mir bla bla bla
bla bla und so wird es geschrieben also
kein stalker t systems sondern ein
riester
aber trotzdem glaube ich es wäre möglich
dass zwei leute das abwechselnd vorlesen
haben wir jetzt vielleicht haben wir
jetzt zwei andere menschen die das
machen wollen gibt es zwei freiwillige
die das machen
vielleicht jemand der weiter hinten ist
weil dann hören alle besser insofern
dass sie das lesen von da lesen können
jemand freiwillig nicht alle auf einmal
es war leichter leute zu finden die an
die zelle glauben
so liegt das vorlesen mit meinem schönen
deutsch ok just vor
hier ist durch zarate
wir nennen doch etwas gleich in meinem
nicht ein holz dem andern oder einem
stein dem anderen noch irgendetwas
dergleichen sondern außer diesem ein
etwas anderes das gleiche selbst sagen
wir dass das etwas ist oder nichts
gewiss beim zeus flaschenhals ganz
entschieden erkennen wir auch dieses was
es ist allerdings woher nahmen wir aber
seine erkenntnis nicht aus dem was wir
eben sacken
wenn die hütte oder steine oder irgend
andere gleiche dinge sein haben wir
nicht bei diesen uns jenes vorgestellt
was doch verschiedenes von diesen oder
scheint es dir nicht verschieden zu sein
bedenke es nur auch so erscheinen die
nicht gleiche steine oder hölzer ganz
die seiten bleiben bis sein als gleich
und dann wieder nichts oh ja die aber
die gleichen dinge ich selbst erscheint
hier bisweilen als ungleich und etwa
auch die gleichheit ungleichheit
nimmermehr wolf soccer teams also sprach
es in jene gleichen dinge und dieses
gleich ist es nicht dasselbe offenbar
keineswegs ockert ist doch aber bei
jenen gleichen verschiedenen von diesem
gleichen hast du die erkenntnis des
letzteren vorgestellt oder erhalten
vollkommen richtig indem es ihnen
entweder ähnlich ist oder ohne freilich
und das macht ja sprach er keinen
unterschied denn so oft du etwas sehen
also er ist so katja seine erzählung was
gesagt
das macht daher keinen unterschied denn
so ob du etwas sehen von dieser gesichts
wahrnehmung aus dir noch ein anderes
vorstellt es sei nämlich oder unendlich
so ist notwendig dieses vorstellen eine
änderung gewesen allerdings wie aber
weiter sprach er begegnet uns war es so
etwas bei den gleichen holzen und
anderen von denen wir eben sprachen
seite 2 scheinen sie uns ebenso gleich
zu sein die das gleiche selbst oder
fällt etwas daran dass die nicht so sind
wie das gleiche oder nichts grafisch
lagerfeld daran müssen wir nun nicht
gestehen wenn jemand der etwas sieht
bemerkt dieses was er sehen will zwar
seien die etwas gewisses anderes es
bleibt aber zurück und vermag nicht so
zu sein wie jenes sondern ist schlechte
dass der welcher dies bemerkt notwendig
jenes vorher kennen muss von dem er sagt
dass das andere teams war gleiche aber
doch dahinter zurückbleiben notwendig
und wie geht es uns nun somit den
gleichen dingen und dem gleichen selbst
auf alle weise notwendig also kennen wir
das gleiche schon von jener zeit als wir
zuerst gleiches erblicken bemerkten dass
alles der gleichen services sein wie das
gleiche aber doch dahinter zurückbleiben
so ist es aber auch das geben wir dazu
dass wir eben dieses nirgend anders her
bemerkt haben noch imstande sind es zu
bemerken
also bei dem sehen oder berühren oder
irgendeiner anderen
denn diese sind mir alle einerlei aber
doch an den wahrnehmung die
wahrnehmungen muss man bemerken dass
alles so in den wahrnehmungen
vorkommende jenem nachstellt was das
gleiche ist und dass es dahinter zurück
bleibt
oder wie wollen wir sagen wir also
anfingen zu sehen oder zu hören oder die
anderen sinne zu gebrauchen müssen wir
schon irgendwo her die erkenntnis
bekommen haben das eigentlich gleichen
was es ist wenn wir dort das gleiche in
den wahrnehmungen so auf jenes beziehen
sollten dass dergleichen alles was gut
zu sein wie jenes aber doch immer
schlechter ist okay ich schlage vor wir
sollten das argument so verstehen also
fangen wir mit diesem beispiel an
also es geht um das gleiche wenn es
hoffentlich mal mit diesen stars klar
bei hat klappt das wort gleich ungefähr
50 mal gesagt okay was wäre übrigens
gleich und das gleiche ist eine idee was
die form des gleichen das gleiche an
sich könnte man sagen
was er sagen will ist irgendwas über
unser verständnis des gleichen ansicht
also wie ist es dass wir sozusagen mit
diesem begriff umgehen können
das besetzen wir jeden tag also das
haben wir das können wir sozusagen
problemlos verwenden diese idee aber wo
haben wir diesen begriff herr
offensichtliche idee es kommt davon dass
wir gleiche dinge sehen und dann
entnehmen wir die idee des gleichen aus
diesen dingen zum beispiel da stellen
wir vor dass zwei menschen hier gleich
groß sind
wir können zwei finden aber stellen sie
einfach vor jetzt jemand hier
das ist ein problem ich weiß nie wie
groß ich bin in zentimeter die größten
sie ist jemand 185
die größen sind sie ist sonst jemand
hier 1.16 ich dachte vielleicht ist doch
nehmen ist sonst jemand hier 185 das
typisch ich hab sofort den einzigen
ausgesucht der größer ist als alle
anderen so lustig dass er ganz vorne
setzt auch weil er am leichtesten von
weit weg sehen kann irgendwas sie sind
175 gewährt
ich komme zurück zu diesen ungefähr das
war interessant ist sonst jemand hier
1.6 ich super dankeschön jetzt werde
nicht mehr zeit hätte würde ich sie
beide ein laden hier wollen zu stellen
aber das wollen sie wahrscheinlich nicht
oder
ok also die sind gleich groß die zwei
damen und man könnte deswegen denken wie
komme ich auf diese idee des gleichen
ich sehe zum beispiel die 2 und dann
denke ich auch sie sind gleich groß also
ich vergleiche sie und ich sehe dass sie
gleich großen und daher habe ich diese
diesen begriff gleichheits oder das
gleiche an sich und solche die sagen das
kann nicht sein
warum nichts sagt dann wenn wir holz
oder steine oder irgend andere gleiche
dinge seien zum beispiel gleiche damen
haben wir nicht bei diesen und jenes was
doch verschiedenes von diesen oder
scheint es der nicht verschieden zu sein
bedenke nur auch so erscheinen die nicht
gleich ist eine ode holzer ganz dieselbe
bleiben bisweilen als gleich und dann
wieder nicht
und die frage ist was dieser satz heißt
war daran liegt dass ganze dass das ist
der haupt schritten dem argument und
platon forscher sind nicht einig
was hier abläuft also was der was sein
gedanke ist dass dahinter steckt aber es
gibt zwei haupt erklärungen
eine erklärung ist was sie gesagt haben
ungefähr
also vielleicht wenn sie beide das
musikmachen aber vielleicht nehmen sie
vorkommen würden und sie von oben
betrachten würden dann versuchen zu
sagen
sind sie wirklich gleich groß und dann
schauen sie ganz genau hin und sie
nehmen so wissenschaftliche instrumente
und dann messen wir die zwei damen und
dann sehen wir was a die sind ganz
gleich groß sie sind ein also 0.02
millimeter größer als sie doch also sie
sind doch nicht gleich okay also das ist
eine idee also wir haben in diesem in
seinem beispiel haben wir zwei stöcke
und die zwei hölzer und die die sind
fast gleich lang aber nicht ganz gleich
aber das ist natürlich so überzeugend
und fällt auch nicht auf als
offensichtliches eine offensichtliche
beobachtung weil mein sie mir sagte
einfach ja kein problem also sehen wir
es stimmt gleich sofort zu sind gleich
zu h sind sofort zu das gleichheits so
funktioniert dass dieselbe sache
derselbe bleiben mal gleich sind man
nichts
also es scheint nichts zu sein dass die
sachen fast gleich sind aber nicht ganz
viel mehr ist die idee wahrscheinlich
folgendes sie sind ihr gleich groß aber
ihn überhaupt nichts also er ist 20
zentimeter größer also wir haben
die die 2 das sind sie
und dann haben wir
das sind sie
dass das gestreiftes t shirt was wir
haben und dann haben wir gehen
und die idee ist
sie sind mit ihr gleich groß und mit ihm
nicht gleich groß also die ids sie sind
gleichzeitig gleich und nicht gleich
dass die der anderes beispiel und hier
werde ich keinen publikums mitglied
nehmen weil es wäre vielleicht
beleidigend lokatis in einem anderen
dialog sagt nehmen wir allen die die
frau die entführt wurde in der in dem
elias haben sie ist im vergleich zu
anderen frauen schön also sie angenommen
sie ist die schönste frau der welt aber
eine göttin ist sie nicht schön also im
vergleich zu einer göttern ist sie nicht
schön aber im vergleich so einen haben
so allen anderen frauen
es ist schön sie ist deswegen
gleichzeitig schön und nicht schön oder
selbst nehmen wir zum beispiel das
beispiel was wir vorhatten ein arzt oder
irgendetwas zurückgeben also zurück zu
geben was man schuldet ist richtig oder
gerecht manchmal mag man nichts
das heißt in englischsprachigen
literatur heißt dass kampfjets
ich weiß nicht ob es sein geld eine
geläufige übersetzung dafür auf deutsch
gibt aber so was wie das zusammensein
der entgegengesetzten und platons idee
ist anscheinend das sinnlich
wahrnehmbare dinge in der welt um uns
herum haben immer so sagen dieses
problem weil sie die leiden will alle an
dieses an diesem zusammenseins der
entgegengesetzten das heißt sie sind
immer gleich und nicht im vergleich zu
anderen eine anderes beispiel das er
benutzt in der polit er das vielleicht
das klarste beispiel und übrigens das
eine gute begründung diese ist so
auszulegen dass ausgelegt habe war in
der politik wird anscheinend denn gleich
einen punkt gemacht aber viel klarer
das sagt nehmen wir diese finger diese
finger also ringfinger ist klein im
vergleich zu der mittelfinger und großen
vergleich zu den kleinen finger also
gleichzeitig groß und nicht groß oder
groß und klein
warum ist das wichtig seine idee ist und
jetzt wird es kontrovers aus diesen aus
dass aus einer un- beobachtung dieser
frau kann man die idee der gleichheit
nicht gewinnen weil diese frau doch
ungleich ist auch wie kann man die idee
der gleichheit auch aus einem ungleichen
ding gewinnen
oder wie könnte man zum beispiel die
idee des großen aus anfänger gewinnen
wenn dieser finger auch klein ist hat
keinen cent
trotzdem arbeiten wir mit dieser mit
diesen begriffen das gleiche waren keine
probleme damit
so sollen wir sagen
das wir sonst irgendwie auf diese als
diese begriffe kommen und dann sagt er
woher also hier das lässt sich nicht
wieder vor aber wir kriegen sie nicht
aus irgendeiner vernehmung sondern
anderswo her nämlich von einheits aus
einer zeit bevor wir wahrnehmung hatten
nämlich bevor wir geboren wurden und
jetzt kommen wir endlich zurück so der
unsterblichkeit der seele
also es ist eine idee ist das kann
seine idee ist dass an die seele
die serie im moment oder am anfang ist
unwissens aber trotzdem kann man wissen
irgendwie erlangen kann wissen wieder
erwerben
das kann nur deswegen seien weil sie
sich an vorheriges essen erinnert aber
um das zu tun muss die seele schon
irgendwann all dieses wissen gehabt
haben und es war anscheinend bevor wir
wahrnehmung hatten deswegen muss sie die
seele schon existiert haben bevor sie in
den körper war also das ist interessant
war hier beweist ja die unsterblichkeit
der seele nicht dadurch dass er weiß
dass dies eben noch existieren wird
nachdem wir sterben oder nachdem der
körper stirbt sondern er beweist dass
diese schon vor der geburt existiert hat
übrigens an die die freunde sagen
vielleicht ist gibt es dann eine eine
andere zeit um die säle das wissen
verloren hat und sage dieses behauptet
dass das wissen sozusagen verloren
gegangen ist oder in die erinnerung ein
eingetreten ist staat aktiv dort einen
baum zu sein mit dem geburts also einst
so genannte schock für die seele in
einem körper rein zu kommen und das ist
der dass mutter das ist die zeit nur die
serie alles vergisst
also alles wird vergessen im moment des
geburtshauses so ein schock ist für die
seele
und dann muss man mühsam für die
restliche zeit des lebens das wissen
wieder rennen aber nicht nur erwerben
nur er wird nur irgendwie der von der
erinnerung vieler hervorgerufen dass das
zweite argument okay zwei sachen zu
diesem argument ein eine sache ist dass
das hier informationen bekommen die
wichtig ist dem was für letzte woche
betrachtet haben weil letzte woche wenn
sie sich daran erinnern h gab es die
frage wie ernst wird diese video oder
mysterie überhaupt nehmen sollen
sie habe dabei manche sagen nein das ist
nur mit harfe in artis muss diese was
ich erfunden habe denn immer noch stolz
darauf aber andere sagen nein nein er
will wirklich behaupten dass die selbst
schon gelebt hat und hier sehen wir dass
erwiderung wirklich mit einer
buchstäblichen existenz der zelle vor
dem geburtstag verbindet das würde ich
würde sagen das paar soll die art
auslegung stark machen des - die sagt
die seele hat wirklich davor existiert
ja
das war toll
wenn die seele der stürzte
sind in dieser konzeption bei der
diese kommen gar nicht erst später die
letzten zehn minuten spaß
voraussetzung
ist
natürlich
sorry ist sagt also ein grund warum er
so sagen optimistisch ist dass das was
nach dem tod für ihn gut ist und nicht
schlecht ist dass er wieder wissen dann
erwerben kann also erfreut sich ein
nicht darauf zu sterben es gibt ein
langes gespräch darüber ob philosophen
sich für den tod vorbereiten
versprechen sie und dann sagt sorge
dieses jahr weil sie versuchen die ganze
zeit wissen zu erwerben und beim sterben
wird diese vollbracht dieses versuch
wieder wissen zu erwerben
also ja das ist genau was er sagen will
kann das zweite übrigens was ich zu dem
argument sagen wollte und dass wir zu
dem dritten hören ist folgendes nehme an
wir sind überzeugt von diesem argument
dass die seele schon vor dem geburt
existiert hat können wir sicher sein
dass die zelle immer wieder zurückkommen
wird aus dem herzen wenn schon natürlich
beide das erste irgendein zeigt
angeblich immer tot dann wieder lebend
ist also gestorben
gestorben mein zyklus aber es selbst mit
dem zweiten akt kann man das natürlich
nicht erreichen aus dem zweiten argument
kann man nur feststellen dass die seele
schon vielleicht sehr lang existiert hat
aber vielleicht nicht mehr nachdem man
dieses mal stirbt und einer von denen
komplett schlägt sogar ein ähnliches
beispiel vorhersagt vielleicht ist sind
die körper wie mental
also wir nehmen jemand der einen mantel
hat und die seele ist wieder der mann
und der körper sein körper ist wie ein
mantel
wenn der körper stirbt das ist wie ihr
mantel dann so alt wird und dann müssen
sie das wegschmeißen
und dann haben sie einen neuen markt und
dann haben sie vielleicht 30 menschen
durch ihr leben aber irgendwann verliert
man das letzte und dann ist vorbei und
dann stirbt der markt also die das
sozusagen die die körper werden jeweils
veraltet und werden weggeworfen und bei
jedes mal zuerst überlebte der mann der
den mantel besitzt also hier die seele
die einen körper besitzt aber nach einer
weile stirbt zur man also die idee ist
nur ich vorher gesagt habe vielleicht
geht die gleiche szene durch den körper
und dann bei dem letzten körper körper
ex stirbt der körper und mit ihm
dieselben und deine schluss also das ist
was er fürchtet es ist würde heißen
jetzt ist sollte dies im körper ex also
schlechte nachrichten
da es in den letzten körper den er
bekommen wird und er kann schon wissen
wieder erinnern weil er so lange
existiert hat dann hat alles gelernt wie
man ihn nennen erfährt aber dieses mal
wirklich sterben
das ist die herausforderung und um das
abzuwarten sagte gysi habe ein gutes
argument die das sogenannte affinität
argument und dieses argument ist ganz
einfach deswegen habe ich das zum zu den
letzten minuten das zu den letzten
runden nicht erwähnt oder erklärt die
der hier ist es gibt die seele
und dann gibt es sachen die das gleiche
also die ideen über formen zum beispiel
das gleiche an sich das große an sich
gerechtigkeit an sich was auch immer und
die behauptung hier ist die seele und
die sachen diese sachen die die seele
versteht wovon sie erkenntnis hat sie
müssen ähnlich sein
die müssen so soll unter logisch der in
selben rang haben und diese ideen und
formen sind körperlich und ewig deswegen
muss die zelle auch um körperlich und
ewig sein weil sonst würde sie nicht
zueinander passen
sozusagen und hier haben wir sehr stark
den eindruck dass platon wirklich so
sagen ein platten ist ist also unter
platin ist verstehen wir normalerweise
die idee es gibt sozusagen zwei bereiche
der ontologie es gibt die ideenwelt
sachen die ewig sind unveränderbar
notwendig um körperlich und so weiter
und dann gibt es die körperliche welt
und die seele ist auf der anderen seite
dieser spaltung von den körper also man
könnte sagen dass im allgemeinen
diese unterscheidung ist eine
unterscheidung nicht nur in uns zwischen
unserer seele und unserem körper sollen
zwischen zwei welten die zellen welt wo
die formen sich auch befinden und
vielleicht auch die götter wenn es gott
gibt und dann die körperliche feld wo
wahrnehmbare dinge existieren und das
interessante an denen mensch werde
natürlich dass wir sozusagen einen fuß
in beiden welten haben also wir haben
diese ein teil was um körperlich ist und
transzendenz über körperlichen gänge
aber über sitzen auch einen körper das
scheint platte uns überzeugung seien vor
allem in diesem dialog allerdings wenn
er das sagen will gibt es mächtige
probleme zum beispiel was ist die
verbindung zwischen diesen zwei ebenen
also wie kann die cell welt oder
ideenwelt die körperliche welt
beeinflussen was haben sie miteinander
zu tun
und das ist genau was für nächste woche
beschlossen werden bei nächste woche
werden wir sehen war was laut platon die
ideen leisten können um unsere welt zu
erklären
dankeschön